les changes que nous avons aujourd'hui
se situe dans le cadre on va dire de la
mission de cette délégation aux
collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation et nous avons depuis
janvier 2020 le sénat a en tout cas à la
demande du président de la république a
dressé la même demande au président de
l'assemblée le sénat a engagé une
réflexion sur les évolutions
potentielles est nécessaire de
l'organisation territoriale dans le
cadre de la réflexion suscitée par le
président de la république après le
mouvement des gilet jaune après le grand
débat où on a ressenti une expression
extrêmement forte
assez générale d'un besoin de la part
des territoires d'une respiration et
d'une liberté c'est une expression que
le formatage qui avait peut-être prévalu
au moment des lois de territoriale
n'était pas le garant de l'efficacité
mais qu'il fallait aussi vrai à partir
de l'intelligence territoriale dont le
sénat sous la présidence de son
président biya a constitué un groupe de
travail réunissant l'ensemble des
groupes politiques du sénat et a émis 50
propositions en faveur des libertés
locales c'est le titre qui a été donné
et qui ont été remises au président de
la république et qui ont eu
l'assentiment si je puis dire de
l'association territoires unis qui je
rappelle rassemble l'association des
maires de france l'association du
département et l'association des régions
de france
parallèlement le gouvernement a annoncé
son souhait de prendre en compte toute
cette expression de liberté locale
en tout cas de souplesse eu avec
l'élaboration d'une loi dite des mois
jeudi des tout court parce que je ne
sais pas combien il y en a il y en
aura-t-il un nous ne savons pas et est
donc des consultations vous avez
d'ailleurs été consulté à france urbain
est aujourd'hui le sénat comme beaucoup
d'associations et en attente de la
présentation d'un texte donc nous nous
avons eu par l'intermédiaire de marlboro
une présentation on va dire de quelques
thématiques de ce texte et nous sommes
aujourd'hui en attend de l'inscription
dans un calendrier législatif qui n'est
pas le cas mais le sénat chambre des
territoires a poursuivi on va dire sa
mission à l'issue de ces 50 le
proposition pas l'adoption de deux
propositions de loi une proposition loi
constitutionnelle qui inscrit le
principe dans le transfert de
compétences donc qui décident paye
voilà donc c'est très simple mais c'est
très clair et une proposition de loi
organique et aujourd'hui nous lançons
aujourd'hui vraisemblablement messieurs
d'or c'est noël starting blocks
une consultation à l'intention de tous
les élus locaux sur leur expression par
rapport à l'essentiel des 50
propositions que senna a fait et nous
poursuivons également nos auditions et
notre dialogue avec l'ensemble des
partenaires acteurs de de cette
réflexion sur les besoins d'évolution
notre organisation territoriale qui
parfois ne parle qu'aux initiés que nous
sommes c'est quand on parle
décentralisation des complexification je
veux dire on a perdu le seul auditeurs
qui pouvait nous accompagnent et qui
était un citoyen et je pense que ce qui
nous guide et l'objectif c'est
l'efficacité de l'action publique et la
crise sanitaire a montré
dans beaucoup de situations combien il
était nécessaire d'avoir un état
puissant et faut recentrer sur ses
compétences régaliennes et qu'en même
temps le dernier kilomètre ne pouvait
être effectuée que par des collectivités
agile agile souple et très est très
réactif
donc voilà le cadre que je voulais que
je voulais poser et nous savons que le
conseil économique social et
environnemental a aussi votre rapport en
est un exemple beaucoup réfléchi sur ces
sujets et la délégation a pour mission
de défricher les shows d'explorer des
points de vue qui peuvent être on va
dire très différent complémentaires et
divergents parce qu'on sait que la
question de l'organisation territoriale
et de l'efficacité de l'action publique
n'est pas une question simple quel
qu'elles peuvent varier selon les
territoires selon la culture selon la
géographie de ces territoires et qu'on
ne peut pas la définir en un modèle on
va dire mathématiques calculé à partir
d'un danseur mais qui viennent question
de liberté mais aussi de responsabilité
des élus et ça n'est pas et c'est donc
avant de vous passer la parole je
souhaiterais vous poser quelques
questions mais auquel vous répondrais
très certainement dans votre
présentation
les métropoles dont on a vu l'objectif
initial des métropoles qui était en fait
un besoin de répondre à un ancrage en
tout cas d'une un besoin d'efficacité
économique dans un monde où la
performance nécessité la taille
ensuite on a vu que cette définition
initiale et beaucoup évolué puisque
maintenant nous avons plus d'une
vingtaine de métropole qui sont très
différentes entre elles donc on a
beaucoup de questions sur la gouvernance
des métropoles permettait d'assurer
fonctionnement harmonieux entre des
communes puisque là on va dire un pci
est considéré soit comme un outil de
coopération entre communes pour faire
ensemble ce qu'on peut pas faire seul ou
un outil d'intégration sachant que la
métropole est une catégorie de pc un peu
particulière puisque l a7
elle était construit je dis souvent
comme un avion de chasse pour être
performant en matière de compétition
internationale et parfois on la
transforme en avions-cargos ce qu'on va
lui laisser la voir à gérer la voirie et
nippon comment on peut faire ça et
pourquoi on peut s'organiser la
gouvernance et de complexité des
démissions
quel est votre point de vue sur on va
dire la différenciation qui pourrait se
créer au sein des métropoles comme au
sein des régions du département ou de
tout repos pci sur une différenciation
géographique de l'exercice des
compétences se dire est ce qu'il est
nécessaire et indispensable et efficace
que la métropole exerce sur l'ensemble
de son territoire la compétence de la
même manière ou est ce qu'il ya des
besoins spécifiques qui ferait qu'on
prendrait en compte des différenciations
dans l'exercice d'engagement et
proximité qui ne traitait pas des
métropoles nous nous avons parlé de
l'intérêt metropolit a c'est un peu la
suite de ma question c'est à dire est ce
que une compétence elle doit s'exercer
dans la totalité de son acceptation ou
est-ce que l'on définit l'exercice de
cette compétence à partir d'un intérêt
métropolitain et puis question
fondamentale qui est l'objet aussi de
votre réponse c'est qu'elle liaison
qu'il vient entre la métropole et son
environnement est ce que j'appelle
l'hinterland
c'est toute la question métropole le
vié de développement où certains
emploient des mots très durs outils
d'asphyxié des territoires voisins je
sais pas mon mot mais je dis je dis ce
que j'entends et est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
on n'est pas plus tôt dans un besoin de
coordination et d'articulation des
territoires parce que certains disques
des périmètres administratifs sont
quelque peu artificielle par rapport au
bassin de vie des gens bassin de
mobilité est ce qu'il n'ya pas de
nécessité aujourd'hui de faciliter des
coopérations des contractualisations des
accords de réciprocité et puis juste
pour clore mon intervention là nous ne
sommes pas du tout volontaire mis
désireux et nous ne le ferons pas de
proposer un nouveau big bang territorial
parce que nous pensons que le big bang
territorial qui a été fait dans toutes
ces lois successives nous émettons un
certain nombre de critiques sur ce big
bang territorial mais nous ne pensons
pas avoir atteint le graal big man c'est
à dire que nous ne prétendons pas avoir
la vérité sur un nouveau big man nous la
position du cncd voilà il ya une
organisation qui existe bien des lois on
n'y touche pas parce que ç'a aussi été
très compliqué pour les élus d'avancé on
ne peut pas passer son temps à monter
démonter une maison parce qu'il ya le
service aux habitants par contre ne
faut-il pas un peu comme cela a été fait
d'engagement et proximité donner de
l'oxygène de la respiration permettre
plutôt qu'imposer et donc faciliter ce
que nous nous nous appelons la dé la
différenciation parce que ça nous semble
extrêmement important mais aussi la
déconcentration et la crise sanitaire
on l'a bien montré voilà donc j'étais un
peu bavarde en introduction mais c'était
important que vous ayez le point de nos
réflexions dont nous disposions je crois
de temps qui devrait nous conduire je
regarde marque le d'or 10h50
il a ainsi promis collègues nous aurons
un point sur un point d'étape sur le
rapport extrêmement important qui est
menée par notre collègue philippe
dallier et un autre co rapporteurs
didier en bout sur ce que j'appelle moi
provincial l'espace parisien
chacun vous voyez voilà qui peut être
considéré comme un objet non identifié
mais voilà je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la présidente
nous vous renouvelons des remerciements
très sincères mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices mesdames et
messieurs les membres de la délégation
merci d'abord grandement pour cette
invitation à partager avec vous un
premier bilan un premier point de vue
de nos métropoles pour tenter de
contribuer à nourrir la réflexion dieu
du législateur je voudrais saluer ici au
préalable et ce n'est pas de la simple
courtoisie véritablement le travail de
fond de constance et de qualité menée
par la délégation aux collectivités du
sénat vous me permettrait d'avoir un mot
pour vos prédécesseurs
monsieur andy rain dogs qui est monsieur
y est rapporteur de la loi
mapa mais c'est vrai que historiquement
les échanges ont toujours été soutenus
et de qualité je crois qu'on ne peut pas
faire un premier bilan des métropoles en
faisant l'économie du contexte global
ce que ce bilan des métropoles il
n'aurait pas de sens il était en quelque
sorte hors sol et on voit bien qu'on le
partage aujourd'hui dans un contexte
national où globalement quand même me
semble qu'on peut se rejoindre les uns
et les autres a observé le fait que le
pacte démocratique
le pacte républicain même de ce pays et
parfois abîmés et qu'il convient sans
doute d'en prendre toute la mesure si on
veut trouver les bons leviers
vous avez évoqué à l'instant comment la
crise des îles et jaune a pesé sur les
débats qui nous réunissent aujourd'hui
allant parfois jusqu'à donner
l'impression qu'il y aurait des perdants
et des gagnants du redécoupage entendue
au sens institutionnel devrait démarrer
en partageant deux éléments très
factuelle est donc incontestable qui
doivent nous amener je crois à nuancer
très largement ses propos le premier
c'est que j'allais dire dans ce mythe
qu'on nous raconte ou qu'on se raconte
parfois où toutes les métropoles serait
riche et tous les territoires où serait
pauvre il me semble qu'on oublie un
élément déterminant c'est que jusqu'à
preuve du contraire dans notre pays
l'immense majorité des grandes poches de
précarité les quartiers politique de la
ville sont à l'intérieur de la métropole
et cet élément au factuel on doit
prendre en considération le deuxième
peut être partagé avec vous que à
l'intérieur de france urbaine dans la
diversité de nos membres
50 % des communes qui sont membres de
france urbaine soit otites grandes
villes soient petites intercommunalités
communauté d'agglo métropole
sont des communes qui sont classés par
l'insee comme communes rurales j'insiste
sur ce point parce que là aussi il me
semble que ça amène une vision plus
nuancée des métropoles qui ont
effectivement vocation à traduire une
responsabilité particulière dans notre
pays je crois qu'on est en fait les uns
et les autres quel que soit le niveau de
territoire confrontés à des nouveaux
défis le premier me semble être celui de
la fragmentation de notre société et je
ne prends pas cette fragmentation elle
soit seulement territoriale je crois
qu'elle est d'abord sociale bien sûr
elle peut avoir une traduction spatial
il faut la regarder il faut en prendre
la mesure mais je crois que les enjeux
d'urgence écologique et précarité de
montée de la pauvreté et je crois pour
ma part que la question de la pauvreté
sera des questions majeures de notre
pays en 2021 ton contexte de crise
sanitaire et donc de crise sociale dans
lequel nous sommes se pose à tous les
territoires ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que sans doute que le sujet qui
nous incombent c'est davantage les
réponses que la société amen à ces
sujets le projet de société qu'on
entendait construire et que de ce point
de vue certes les métropoles ont une
responsabilité particulière on va y
revenir mais qu' on peut convenir que
ces enjeux dépassent le strict champ de
nos métropoles
il me semble que ce n'est pas inutile si
on veut avancer sur nos sujets peut-être
d'essayer de se replacer une seconde si
vous le permettez dans le temps long de
nos métropoles parce que nos métropoles
se sont d'abord des communautés humaines
je ne crois pas une seule seconde que ce
soit le redécoupage institutionnel qui
est créé les métropoles en réalité quand
on regarde braudel par exemple on voit
bien que l'exode rural le rapport au
travail la nécessité de concentration
ont amené les hommes et les femmes à se
regrouper autour de leur fleuve
notamment autour de leurs portes
regardez le nombre de métropoles qui
sont irrigués par un fleuve roi bien que
la dimension géographique et historique
de notre pays a beaucoup compter ce
n'est qu'ensuite que le redécoupage que
les avancées législatives ont permis de
conforter cette étape que ce soit
d'abord par les grandes lois de
décentralisation 80 90
considérant que les métropoles font
partie plus globalement de ce qu'on a
l'habitude de qualifier le bloc communal
puis la loi est rejeté et la loi ma
femme mais qui en quelque sorte n'a fait
que poser un nouveau jalon dans une
histoire de nos intercommunalités qui
est en réalité une histoire qui a
aujourd'hui plus de 50 ans au delà de
ses fonctions métropolitaines absolument
essentiel puisque la loi m'a pas mal je
le rappelle renforcer le rôle de ces
métropoles notamment avec cette question
d'un développement économique qui
devient une compétence partagée entre
métropoles et les régions je le dis
d'autant plus je suis prête à y revenir
dans les échanges que l'état semble dans
la période parfois l'oublier et que cela
me semble regrettable y compris si on
veut réussir le plan de relance qui me
semble aujourd'hui en effet
indispensable à notre pays mais au delà
de ses fonctions métropolitaines
proprement dit
ce sont en réalité des figures de
gouvernance et y compris des situations
juridiques qui sont différentes
parmi nos métropoles entre le grand lyon
et les métropoles de droit commun mais
même parmi la vingtaine de métropole que
vous avez évoquées et je crois que c'est
une illusion d'optique de considérer
qu'il n'y aurait qu'une situation de
métropole ne serait-ce que si on prend
la question démographique entre des
métropoles comme celle de nantes ou
celle de rennes qui gagnent des
habitants tous les ans et des métropoles
qui n'ont pas cette dynamique
démographique bien forcément les
réponses en termes de politiques
publiques par exemple sur le champ des
transports en commun n'ont pas vocation
avec les mêmes parce que la réalité
sociologique démographiques économiques
de nos métropoles mais pas homogène
j'insiste là dessus parce que je crois
que si nos métropoles ont construit des
gouvernances pour commencer à répondre à
ce premier point de votre question qui
sont des gouvernances parfois différent
c'est justement pour tenter de répondre
à ces enjeux avec une phrase que vous
avez évoquées qui est aussi souvent la
mienne est de dire la métropole c'est
d'abord des communes qui se mettent
ensemble pour faire des choses qu'aucune
d'entre elles y compris la ville centre
ne serait capable de faire seule c'est
vraiment cette capacité à mettre en
commun à considérer qu'on a un destin
commun pour faire des choses ensemble à
la fois en termes de rayonnement mais
aussi vous l'avez évoqué en termes de
gestion des services de proximité
alors aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation dans notre pays où certains
on voit les métropoles comme la source
de tous les maux et puis d'autres les
métropoles comme le berceau de toutes
les dynamiques positives
il me semble qu'un peu de nuance nous
permettrait sans doute de de progresser
dans le débat certains disent que les
métropoles sont responsables des
classements d'autres territoires dans un
pays où qu'elles n'ont pas permis des
économies d'échelle avec une gestion des
ressources irraisonnée je me permets de
dire que cela et faire fi des sujets sur
lequel l'état s'est délesté en droit ou
de fait d'un certain nombre de
compétences
je pense à la question de la sécurité
dans nos grandes villes je pense à
l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile qui
pourtant dans le cadre d'un état
régalien telle que vous la pieds de vos
voeux douar est assumé par l'état ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui donc il
faut prendre en compte toutes ses
dimensions si on veut pouvoir avoir une
lecture la plus objective et de la
situation et puis on assiste ici ou là
depuis plusieurs années maintenant
parfois une forme de remise en question
un peu systématique de la dimension
intercommunale je crois vraiment quand
par transport en commun quand on parle
gestion des déchets quand on parle
stratégie d'énergie cela nous permet
dans une logique d'intercommunalité de
faire des choses je leur dis qu aucune
commune n'est en situation de faire seul
en tout cas c'est la conviction que nous
avons on fait davantage ensemble et
peut-être ont fait mieux la question du
qualitatif me semble aussi indispensable
alors je crois pour ma part que
peut-être qu'en réalité c'est ce modèle
de société qui est interrogé notre
capacité de résilience aussi à court
terme la crise actuelle et la question
de notre capacité collective à surmonter
ce choc le démo mais aussi les enjeux
structurants les enjeux de fond et je
pense notamment à la question de la
transition écologique et de ce point de
vue la logique que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure en disant finalement les
métropoles elles ont été constitués à la
base pour avoir un effet taille
uniquement sur le champ économique je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les choses sont
beaucoup plus large que ça parce que nos
métropoles
ce sont les lieux où on accueille les
chu il ya donc des enjeux de santé
absolument
joueurs ce sont des lieux de
bouillonnement culturel et je dis pas ça
pour vous inviter les uns et les autres
à découvrir d'autres grands musées d'art
ou le voyage à nantes
ce sont des lieux de valeur ajoutée par
simplement au sens de la valeur
économique
et là on a je crois des choses à
regarder parce que s'il est vrai
qu'historiquement on s'est habitué à
voir les métropoles sur ce champ là la
montée des questions sociales
l'accroissement des précarités et des
pauvretés nous amène sans doute à penser
des choses aussi de point de vue de la
cohésion sociale à l'échelle de nos
métropoles
ça vaut je crois pour les enjeux de
santé et pour les enjeux de longévité
également évidemment quand on aborde ces
sujets vous avez commencé à évoquer la
question du lien entre les communes de
la métropole
et puis ensuite je reviendrai dans un
deuxième temps la question du lien entre
la métropole et l'hinterland pour
reprendre votre exemple ou plus
globalement lien entre les territoires
urbains périurbains et ruraux se pose
aujourd'hui avec force si je m'attarde
un instant sur la question de la
solidarité financière
je voudrais vraiment invité les
parlementaires que vous êtes à regarder
dans le détail si je puis me permette la
manière dont en réalité se passe
les mécanismes de solidarité financière
qui passe à la fois par les choix de
redistribution entre la métropole et les
communes qui passent dans de nombreux
endroits par des fonds de dos tourné
concours que ce soit en investissement
mais certaines métropoles se pose
aujourd'hui la question de fond de
concours en fonctionnement pour venir
soutenir les communes et puis là aussi
je vais prendre deux trois exemples très
précis vous me permettrez de les prendre
à partir de la métropole nantaise sur la
métropole nantaise la plus petite
commune s'appelle saint-léger-les-vignes
à saint léger les vignes
la dotation de solidarité communautaire
donc que la métropole amène à cette
commune ces 14 % du budget de
saint-léger ce que la dgs de l'état
amène à saint léger
ces 8 % ça c'est la réalité des
mécanismes de solidarité financière tels
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
le 2e chiffre que je
vous donnez toujours sur la métropole
nantaise section garde globalement entre
la ds et les fonds de concours que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure l'ensemble des
mécanismes de redistribution entre la
métropole et les communes en réalité
c'est 25 % du budget de fonctionnement
de la métropole nantaise qui est
consacrée à la redistribution aux
communes ça représente à peu près un
budget de 50 euros par habitant certains
analystes financiers c'est y compris un
débat qu'on peut avoir avec la cour des
comptes y voit là un mécanisme
d'intégration qui serait insuffisant
moi j'y vois un choix un choix
stratégique un choix politique au sens
noble du terme qui fait en effet des
logiques de la métropole des logiques au
service des communes dans leur diversité
et dans la diversité géographique que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
en revanche je crois en effet je partage
que c'est un des enjeux de la loi cadre
et que les mécanismes de différenciation
sont attendus parce que les réalités je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure ne sont pas les
mêmes et je crois pour ma part que
l'avenir est plus dans des logiques de
contractualisation renforcer dans des
logiques de coopération soutenue que ce
soit à l'échelle internationale ou à
l'échelle territoire urbain fait l'écho
d'un euro à l'échelle internationale
parce que force est de constater qu'à
par paris aucune de nos métropoles en
réalité dans une économie mondialisée
est susceptible de peser à une valeur
suffisante à l'échelle de
l'international et donc dans l'ouest
nous faisons le pari de l'alliance non
brain brest angers saint nazaire parce
que vu de montréal par exemple eh bien
tout cela c'est le grand ouest
et puis cet enjeu des coopérations entre
les territoires urbains et ruraux pour
le dire rapidement cette alliance des
territoires que j'appelle de mes voeux
et que nous nous efforçons construire un
français au maine en disant sortons de
cette logique d'opposition qui ne
produira pas les solutions attendues
entre les territoires urbains et les
territoires ruraux
d'abord j'ai la conviction que
qu'on soit un jeune issu d'un quartier
populaire où un jeune issu d'un
territoire rural dit délaissé on a
parfois le même sentiment d'abandon du
pacte républicain et que donc notre
sujet collectif c'est comment on envoie
des message d'intégration au sens le
plus plein du terme à cette jeunesse
dans la diversité mais je crois que ça
vaut pour de nombreuses générations j'ai
vraiment la conviction que résilience et
coopération vont de pair et que si je
brosse les choses de manière un peu
rapide on a eu deux modèles de métropole
dans le pays des métropoles qui c'est
vrai on part à un droit à sécher les
territoires autour c'est une réalité
sociologique et économique incontestable
qu'il faut reconnaître les métropoles
qui est de ce point de vue les travaux
de laurent d'asie sont toujours
éclairant ou irriguer les territoires
environnants
est ce que c'est la théorie du
ruissellement versus métropole je ne
sais pas en tout cas je crois pour ma
part que le moment est venu d'inventer
le troisième modèle de métropole est le
troisième modèle de métropole
c'est d'aller chercher toutes les
coopération gagnant gagnant entre un
territoire je prends un exemple très
concret sur la métropole nantaise on a
un objectif de fortement augmenter les
produits bio dans nos cantines ses 15000
euros par jour la métropole nantaise
elle est pas elle sera jamais
autosuffisants d'un point de vue
alimentaire pas plus que d'un point de
vue énergétique
si on considère que c'est un levier pour
mettre autour de la table l'ensemble des
agriculteurs et des éleveurs du
département et travailler à la
structuration de filières alimentaires
renouveler on voit je crois qu'au mans
là on peut aller chercher c'est logique
gagnant gagnant
c'est dans cet esprit qu'un certain
nombre de métropoles ont par exemple
signé des contrats de réciprocité avec
les territoires environnants des
territoires qui ont à coeur de
travailler avec nous sur les sujets
alimentaire sur les sujets de mobilité
on réglera pas la question de la
congestion automobile dans nos grandes
villes
si on refuse de considérer qu'on n'a pas
le même rapport à la voiture
individuelle
quand on habite dans l'hyper centre
d'une grande métropole où quand on
habite à 40 km de son lieu de travail
donc je crois que ces enjeux de
coopération sont absolument essentielles
j'ai vu
et je le salue que le sésame propose par
exemple d'inscrire l'impératif d'une
meilleure coopération entre les
métropoles et leur territoire en
proximité dans la loi et que vous
proposez y compris d'organiser un
développement coordonné des transports
durables à différentes échelles
territoriales je crois que là il ya en
effet vraiment une piste de travail qui
est à travailler nous on est tout à fait
prêt à le faire en lien avec vous si
vous le souhaitez tout ça c'est inscrit
quand même dans une tradition française
qui reste assez jacobine assez
centralisatrice et on voit là qui nous
reste à l'évidence des choses à franchir
moi je suis pour un état fort un état
fort sur le régalien un état fort sur
les dimensions stratégiques je crois que
c'est absolument essentiel est que la
conjugaison d'un état fort et d'un état
stratège mais de la capacité à avant des
territoires qui sont des laboratoires
d'imagination une solution pourrait nous
permettre d'avancer
et là force est de constater que si
l'état parfois transférer les
compétences
nous n'observons pas pour autant qu'il a
transféré la confiance et que en termes
d'efficacité de l'action publique ici ou
là ça pose un certain nombre de sujets
particulièrement dans le moment dans
lequel nous sommes
j'invite vraiment les parlementaires que
vous êtes à vous pencher avec précision
sur l'impact de la situation qu'au vide
sur les finances des grandes villes et
des grandes métropoles deux chiffres
issus d'un travail d'évaluation
extrêmement factuel que je tiens à votre
disposition qu'on a fait en france
humaine au total en termes
d'effondrement
de nos dépenses de fonctionnement c'est
plus d'un milliard et demi et je compte
or paris puisque paris une problématique
spécifique ville département
un milliard et demi ce qui correspond
pour nous à une perte de notre épargne
nette d'un tiers j'évoque ce sujet avec
précision parce que quand je le partage
avec les ministres ils me disent qu'en
réalité les remontées qu'ils ont de
bercy globalise les situations des
collectivités et quand globalise la
situation des collectivités on arrive à
des réponses dans le projet de loi de
finances qui touche 80 % de communes de
moins de 2000 habitants
où est la réponse pour les grandes
villes et pour les grandes métropoles
elle n'est pas sur la table
à ce stade et je crois que ça fait fi
des charges de centralité qui sont
assumés par nos grandes métropoles
au moment où tout le monde constate que
la réponse sanitaire par exemple la
réponse de santé elle est en partie dans
les grands pôles urbains on a donc là
des choses à regarder avec attention
d'autant plus qu' il me semble qu'on a
tous des progrès et des efforts à faire
mais que globalement dans noter
aujourd'hui les collectivités sont bien
gérées qu'en tout cas la règle y compris
en termes d'endettement n'est pas la
même puisque contrairement à l'état nous
pouvons nous en était que pour
l'investissement c'est quand même là un
élément de sécurisation collectif qui me
semble essentielle même s'il ya un sujet
qui monte dans nos villes interco et
métropole je le partage avec vous c'est
que s'il y avait historiquement une
certaine lisibilité entre la fiscalité
locale et le territoire de proximité la
capacité pour ne pas perdre le citoyen
vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure à dire je
paye un impôt pour quel résultat
sur mon territoire les différentes
réformes dernières sont venus à faiblir
en quelque sorte cette lisibilité et je
crois que le chantier d'une fiscalité
locale juste qui garantit la liberté
fiscale des collectivités auraient
toutes raisons de retrouver un agenda de
travail
certains sont prêts à renoncer à leurs
dotations et assumer une péréquation
plus forte en échange d'une réelle
autonomie fiscale parce que d'elle
décentralisation c'est d'abord la libre
administration des collectivités locales
est que nous ne savons pas nous comment
il y a libre administration des
collectivités locales quand il n'ya pas
libérés
c'est de la stratégie fiscale et donc de
la stratégie budgétaire qui est la nôtre
je terminerai par la question de nos
gouvernance interne et externe puisque
vous l'avez évoqué avec un sujet
extrêmement important comment la montée
des métropoles s'est accompagnée d'un
renforcement des gouvernances et
notamment du travail entre les maires
dernier exemple nantais jeu réunit
chaque mois la conférence des maires
chaque mois les maires de toutes
sensibilités politiques de chacune des
communes sont réunis pour partager les
éléments de la stratégie les éléments de
la mise en place ça veut pas dire que
nous sommes d'accord sur tout
heureusement c'est la force et et la
valeur de la démocratie mais que la
dimension collégiale de nos discussions
et affirmée est organisée en revanche je
pense que la question de la gouvernance
ne peut pas s'arrêter au partage entre
élus que la question de la place donnée
aux citoyens et de la citoyenneté
métropolitaine se pose aujourd'hui bon
nombre de nos métropoles ont de ce point
de vue mener un certain nombre
d'initiatives grand débat citoyen par
exemple sur nantes convention citoyenne
en ce moment même pour aller chercher la
parole des habitants lient à la
situation de la crise du collier je
crois qu'on a des dynamiques qui doivent
simplifier
même s'il me semble que nous ne serons
pas totalement au bout de l'exercice si
nous n'allons pas jusqu'à se poser la
question démocratique
je précise là que cette dernière
position n'est pas une position de
france urbaine en tant que thème partagé
par l'ensemble des collègues mais une
position partagée
je crois quand on mesure le budget qui
incombe à nos métropoles aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas faire l'économie de se poser
la question du suffrage universel et que
l'une des missions passionnantes je
crois qui pourrait être celle du
législateur c'est de se dire comment on
préparait
une évolution démocratique qui me
semblerait absolument majeur sans perdre
le lien et se poser la question du rôle
des maires dans cette dimension
en tout cas on peut convenir que le
fléchage est une étape intermédiaire qui
me semble à la fois avoir des avantages
mais on voit bien aussi un certain
nombre de limites
quoi qu'il en soit je crois que le
travail qui aujourd'hui à l'agenda
parlementaire notamment avec la l'autre
4/10 donc france urbaine attend comme
vous
la confirmation de la mise à l'agenda et
que contexte de crise sanitaire qui a
quand même montré me semble-t-il la
capacité des territoires à répondre
présent masques test capacité de
réactivité sur le champ social puissance
logistique d'organisation concrètes dans
nos collectivités doit vous nous invitez
à essayer de faire preuve d'un peu
d'audace et de passer une nouvelle étape
en matière de décentralisation
merci beaucoup madame la présidente a va
vous avez répondu à deux questions
complémentaires et je voulais vous poser
celle de la question du suffrage
universel direct qui a fait l'objet à
chaque fois de beaucoup de débats et qui
pose la question de ce qu'est
l'intercommunalité est ce que c'est une
connectivité à part entière si je puis
dire
ou est ce que c'est le bras à former des
communes sur un principe de subsidiarité
et puis l'importance que vous avez aussi
donné quand vous ai parlé de la
confiance entre l'état et les
collectivités
mais la confiance du citoyen dans ces
institutions 6 à kirti sera le pack de
républicains et vous vous avez parlé de
l'attention que que vous portiez ce
sujet puis juste un petit commentaire on
a aussi au sénat beaucoup de deux débats
et des changes un peu philosophique sur
l'autonomie fiscale et la liberté yann
libre administration des collectivités
mais l'autonomie est souhaitée par
certains discutent et par d'autres qui
disent moi je peux avoir une autonomie
mais qui produit
qui ne produit rien parce que je n'ai
pas de terreau de fertilité d'impôt vous
voyez je ne serai pas plus long que je
vous passe la parole puis ensuite
interviendront donc je ne sais pas
comment vous souhaitez vous monsieur
lasnier j'ai l'impression que c'est vous
qui démarrait voilà je l'avais dit non
vous avez la bonne impression même le
président même madame rôle on a un je
pense a effectivement consulter notre
travail et la quasi résumé donc ça nous
fait c'est ça nous fait si vite
ça nous facilite un petit peu le travail
merci en tout cas de mercier a mené en
tout cas de votre invitation
j'aurais peut-être d'abord resituer le
cadre et la date de notre travail
puisqu'elle est elle est importante par
rapport aux événements que nous vivons
depuis
depuis les derniers mois nous avons
présenté à l'assemblée plénière du
conseil économique et social et
environnemental notre travail en octobre
2019 c'est à dire que nous l'avons
conduit pendant la fin de la crise des
gilets jaunes et le grand débat et nous
l'avons conduit avant la grève des
transports et avant la crise sanitaire
voilà c'est juste pour leur place et
donc les quelques événements qui
émaillent notre vie sociale et
démocratique puisque forcément les
moments que nous vivons en ce moment peu
réinterrogée renforcer je pense un
certain nombre des préconisations que
avec nos collègues nous avions souhaité
souhaité proposer et
pourquoi la section aménagement durable
des territoires qui a un tropisme
peut-être un petit peu plus rurales
s'était lancé dans ce travail
on avait l'impression d'un sujet un peu
café du commerce d'une confusion totale
entre métropole et phénomène de
métropolisation et on a d'abord souhaité
avant de rendre un avis à la place qui
est la nôtre c'est à dire celui de la
société civile organisée faire un petit
peu l'état de l'art sur cette question
puisque vous avez cité monsieur d'asie
mme d'amours long la recherche
universitaire est assez fréquent de sûr
mais avec quand même une logique assez
urbanistique peu sociologique à mon sens
et puis comme les infectiologues qui
succède depuis maintenant dix mois sur
les plateaux de télévision
eh bien nous avons des gens avec des
avis extrêmement tranché et
c'est compliqué en tout cas pour des non
experts ce qui est mon cas de
de se faire une idée et puis nous avions
toujours en tête de pouvoir à la fois
faire la lumière sortir de ces préjugés
et puis aussi analyser un certain nombre
de risques associés à ce modèle puisque
dominique et moi pressentions quand même
que le modèle métropolitain alors c'est
pour ça que j'ai re cité
ce ce temps gilet jaune quoi pouvait
être pouvait être associé à un certain
nombre de difficultés sociales
alors je ne vais pas vous faire l'injure
de vous rappeler les lois qui fondent
les métropoles mais juste quelques
chiffres pour rappeler qu'une métropole
aujourd'hui c'est ont un ensemble de
quatre cent mille habitants où c est
trop au centre d'une zone d'emploi de
quatre cent mille habitants ou être un
opci 250000 habitants et comprendre dans
son périmètre à la date du 31 décembre
le chef-lieu de la région de la zone
d'emploi de plus de cinq cent mille
habitants
je cite ça parce que j'ai l'impression
parfois de lire du ray man de hausse
quand 22 métropole existe dans notre
pays mais dont certaines vous l'avez
rappelé madame roland des statuts
particuliers la métropole du grand lyon
celle du grand paris ou celle d'aix
marseille provence et ça devient
vraiment du raymond devos
quand on se dit que la métropole
européenne de lille ou l'eurométropole
de strasbourg qui ont des dénominations
spécifique non pas de qualités
spécifiques et alors pour vraiment
rendre hommage à ce grand humoriste
quand je vous citerai que les villes
d'avignon et de douai lens qui avait les
conditions pour remplir ce statut
métropolitains ne l'ont pas revendiquer
ou alors qu'une ville j'ai réside à
quelques kilomètres qui s'appelle
chartres s'appelle chartres métropole
eh bien je défie à quiconque et à tout
citoyen de pouvoir s'y retrouver dans
l'organisation aujourd'hui voilà c'était
juste pour vous faire une petite
parenthèse sur c'est sur ces chiffres
deux autres peut-être intéressant les
jeunes de métropole ses 19 millions
d'habitants
et ça n'est que 2 % de la superficie de
notre territoire
donc quand on voit l'importance de
phénomènes métropolitain dans nos débats
par rapport
nous 67 millions d'habitants et à 19
millions dans les métropoles
on se dit qu'il ya aussi des choses qui
peuvent être rééquilibrée alors on a
essayé dans notre rapport de de faire
effectivement un état de là un petit
focus un même rôle on vous avait dit
beaucoup notamment le fait que c'est une
c'est une erreur bien entendu de penser
qu'aujourd'hui les métropoles soit des
territoires de richesse elle concentre
aussi les populations les plus pauvres
les quartiers politique de la ville même
si ça peut exister dans des villes
moyennes bien entendu mais aussi en
milieu rural sont très présents dans les
métropoles
et nous avons aussi alors je sais votre
sensibilité aux questions
d'environnement
une inégalité assez grandissante des
citoyens devant les phénomènes
climatiques à l'intérieur des métropoles
donc il faut et c'était notre objet un
petit peu remettre remettre les choses à
leur place alors pour que nous ayons de
la place au débat je laisserais
dominique mais vous en avez parlé aussi
madame roland insisté sur la question
des contrats de réciprocité qui pourra
être notre sens un vrai chemin pour
créer du lien entre les métropoles et
les territoires et juste faire un focus
sur les questions de gouvernance puisque
vous nous y appeliez madame la
présidente
en vous disant que au moment nous avons
fait ce rapport
une loi
qu'ils s'appellent engagement et
proximité supprimée
l'obligation des conseils des conseils
de développement et
bon on vous imaginez qu'à la place qui
était la nôtre celle de la société
civile c'était pas forcément quelque
chose qui nous réjouit c'est madame
roland vous parliez de la conférence des
maires également je voudrais insister
auprès de vous sur la nécessité
aujourd'hui dans des ensembles qui sont
complexes comme je le rappelais la deux
et puis une sociologie qui est en train
vraiment d'évoluer et un rapport à la
démocratie notamment chez les moins de
40 ans aujourd'hui et qui est vraiment à
étudier il est vraiment important que le
législateur créé les conditions de
l'association la plus forte des citoyens
les décisions publiques alors
il faut je pense être créatif sur ces
questions là parce que des assemblées
connu enfin si on se rappelle les pays
il y a un peu plus de vingt ans
maintenant dans une loi qui date de la
fin des années 90 les empilements le
mille feuilles sont pas forcément
toujours des gages d'efficacité mais on
a un vrai sujet sur sur la question de
l'association des des citoyens à la
décision publique à leur capacité de
pouvoir de pouvoir d'influer alors la
digitalisation de nos vies rang des
choses enfin j'étais dans mon mandat est
terminé
désormais au césium et nous avions
initié avec le président bernasconi un
comité de veille sur les pétitions
citoyennes
et d'ailleurs quelques quelques rapports
sont le fruit de deux sujets que nous
avions repéré comme étant des sujets
portés manière assez forte par les
citoyens je pense qu'au delà de l'acte
pétitionnaires la laddh et la société
civile
le champ associatif on s'en sont
aujourd'hui des chants sur lequel de
l'inspiration peut être trouvée pour
trouver des logiques des associations
des citoyens
dominique je sais pas que tu veut
peut-être continuer sur les contrats de
réciprocité parce que on avait parlé
aussi des du rôle des oui en fait madame
tout à l'heure la manif on nous avait
parlé justement de du fait que vous
réunissiez les maires et dans nos
préconisations
nous avions aussi
pensé qu'il fallait en fait inscrire
dans la loi que une conférence
métropolitaine des maires des communes
de la métropole puisse devenir en fait
une instance obligatoire à fréquence
nous on avait dit au moins bisannuel
parce qu'en fait on s'est rendu compte
au travers de notre rapport qu'il n'y
avait il y avait parfois des uniquement
des techniciens qui venait à la place
des mères les maires pouvaient pas aller
partout
et s'il n'y avait pas de temps à autre
c'est réunion vous pouviez pas leur vous
le faites mais toutes les métropoles ne
le font pas forcément en ce qui concerne
vous nous avez aussi parlé du
ruissellement et il n'a pas forcément de
soi effectivement et les coopérations
entre les métropoles et les
intercommunalités doivent pour nous être
vraiment mieux définis pour participer
au dynamisme global est en fait de par
toutes les problématiques
environnementales et notamment
climatiques
cette coopération entre la métropole et
les territoires va devenir de plus en
plus crucial et on avait en fait indiqué
que les contrats très près de
réciprocité entre la métropole et son
territoire d'interaction d'inscrire
cette impérative dans la loi constitue
constituer notre deuxième préconisations
et semblait être un élément contributif
d'un élément harmonieux du territoire
je vais simplement donner un exemple au
niveau de la métropole de lille qui
avait récemment abandonné l'idée
d'urbaniser tout une zac 1 il y avait au
total une dizaine
deux communes qui devait faire à nouveau
un nouveau quartier nouvelle ville ils
l'ont abandonné en fait l'idée
d'urbaniser parce qu'il s'était rendu
compte en fait que ces communes étaient
gardiennes de l'eau située au sud de
l'île c'était été gardienne de l'eau
pour la métropole de lille est donc
forcément il devait y avoir des contrats
de réciprocité pour aider ces communes
qui avait en quelque sorte elle avait
qu'orange avait bloqué tout
développement peut tout développement
possible et qu'il fallait bien qu'elle
s'y retrouve autrement je pense qu'il ya
un autre phénomène qui va obliger aussi
à réfléchir à ces contrats de
réciprocité c'est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'objectif de zéro
artificialisation hélas j'attire votre
attention je pense que les maires quand
ils vont se rendre compte
l'objectif il est louable c'est c'est
d'une part le terme il est très négatif
vis-à-vis de la population
on a en ça donne un sentiment de
décroissance des gens c'est ça un
problème et donc il va bien falloir que
les territoires s'entendent à ce sujet
là jeu on n'a pas parlé de delà de la
question de la région en fait on s'est
rendu compte aussi que les métropoles
bien entendu vous l'avez dit elle ont
été construits elles sont construites de
longue date qui a eu souvent des hommes
aussi
on peut parler de de l'île de rennes
d'aider des hommes qui ont aidé os
développement de ces dynamiques elles
sont parfois en dualité entre elles mais
il n'ya pas que les métropoles qui ont
un dynamisme et ça il faut le dire parce
qu'on avait on avait cité des exemples
de 2,2 territoire il n'y a pas besoin de
s'appeler notre métropole pour pour être
dynamiques ont par contre ils n'ont pas
s'ils ont des atouts certains ont aussi
quand même pas mal de faiblesse et on
s'est rendu compte qu'elle était souvent
en parfois en dualité vous avez qu
évoqué le tourisme par exemple on
plusieurs fois on a eu l'occasion dans
nos travaux au niveau de la section
aménagement du territoire de se rendre
compte que on devrait partir au niveau
de la vente et du marketing de la france
à l'étranger de partir en bloc et on
part un peu chaque région d or de façon
sol après chaque métropole
chaque territoire et vis-à-vis de
l'étranger c'est pas comme ça qu'on
pourra vendre vent de la france nous
l'est où nous l'a dit d'ailleurs dans
donc après si vous voulez
revenir au niveau de l'économie on voit
qu'il peut y avoir aussi beaucoup de
confusion et nous on en faisait une
préconisation pour affirmer le rôle de
la région en qualité de chefs de file du
développement économique sur le
territoire en collaboration avec les
autres collectivités dont les métropoles
parce que en fait il peut y avoir des
politiques locales qui viennent se
confronter les unes aux autres je
parlais du tourisme mais en matière
d'économie ça peut ça peut arriver aussi
et enfin on pensait que la région devait
reprendre un rôle on va dire à un rôle
pas pas régaliens je sais c'est le désir
même si c'était un film qui nous avait
cité cet exemple entre pro et ils
s'attèleront été soit sur des
implantations d'entreprises qui avait
coûté plusieurs millions on a fait un
bon citoyen par par concurrence par
concurrence entre autres les territoires
trois points en deux minutes
montrer très rapidement j'avais employé
cette image j'y tiens un peu quand nous
avions avec dominique présenter notre
notre travail et
les métropoles sont pour moi la croisée
des chemins entre les ont le choix entre
devenir des phares pour le territoire
mais elles peuvent aussi et
malheureusement on le décèle dans
certaines devenir des châteaux forts et
il ya vraiment il ya vraiment un sujet
alors au delà du ruissellement ou des
capacités et riga territoire moi je
crois beaucoup au sentiment
d'appartenance aussi aux territoires et
je ne peux pas puisque nous avions aussi
auditionné anglaise en votre présence
madame roland salué le travail qui a été
fait à nantes depuis les années 80 sur
la question de la place de la culture
dans la capacité à un territoire de 2 de
fabrique et sa fierté
et puis en plus de fabriquer de
l'émancipation pour les habitants et en
un
j'ai grandi à l'ombre dans ces années là
et donc j'en suis
j'en suis en tout cas je le revendique
un petit peu et puis je voudrais juste
me permettre de vent ou mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
je suis le délégué général des petits
frères des pauvres et donc forcément les
questions de l'ag les questions de
l'isolément social sont au quotidien
j'intervenais hier auprès de la
commission des affaires sociales de la
mf
sur la sensibilisation des élus à ces
questions à la fois de pauvreté vous
l'avez fait un brelan mais aussi
d'isolement social
j'attire notre attention de décideurs
sur la question du vieillissement de la
population sur les 20 ans à venir et de
la place que la ville doit prendre
aujourd'hui pour se préparer à ce
tsunami parce que c'en est un
démographiquement parlant sur sur ces
questions et je pense que là la
métropole a aussi dans une sorte de
compétences nouvelles
un rôle particulier à jouer les
questions se présenter sur mais je pense
qu'on va pouvoir poursuivre au travers
des questions et des échanges parce que
je sais qu'un certain nombre de
collègues ont beaucoup de deux contre un
la vie d'un sénateur est aussi multiples
que si je puis dire la juste un mot sur
ce que et sur votre intervention madame
ce que vous avez fait émerger la
question qui parfois je pose de
l'articulation entre la métropole et la
région et que ce rôle et cette
articulation naturellement mari selon
l'armature urbaine de 2,2 de l'argent et
que parfois il y a un sentiment de
compétition un sentiment de
complémentarité vous l'avez vous vous
l'avez dit donc je crois que les uns et
les autres
vous avez soulevé ensemble des questions
et monsieur le juge je voudrais vous
faire enfin est quoi ce que j'ai dit sur
les conseils de développement il se
trouve que j'étais rapporteur de la loi
engagement et proximité donc je fais
partie de ces gens qui ont pu donner
l'impression de vouloir couper la tête
de des conseils de développement pour
rester entre eux soit pas du tout
moi je suis très favorable et je me bats
pour avoir été du local pendant six ans
quand je regarde la manière dont j'ai
pratiqué rien ne peut se faire sans
une intégration de la vie de la
population fin on n'a même pas besoin
d'inventer des formules toutefois les
conseils de développement me semble être
utile en termes d'outils d'associations
la population au diagnostic et à la
décision ce qui avait été mis en cause
lors du grand débat c'est l'obligation
d'une forme de conseils de développement
qui était académique qui ne
correspondait pas forcément besoin des
territoires et que je connais si des
territoires comme moi où il ya bien un
conseil de développement là on a rempli
le formulaire mais ne s'est jamais
réunie il n'a rien participative
d'accepter dans cet esprit un peu de
liberté donnée aux élus pour exercer
leurs responsabilités en inventant la
forme pardonnez moi alors
et on a beaucoup de prises de parole et
je m'en réjouis donc je vais peut-être
démarré par deux femmes qui ont des
contraintes aussi pardonnez moi
donc sonia de la provôté et sylvie
robert ensuite didier rambaud
si on peut voilà concentrés ils vont
être plus efficace que moi dans
l'exercice de concision je remercie donc
sonia sylvie et didier
merci beaucoup sonia oui bonjour merci
madame la présidente et merci beaucoup
de ces interventions est très
intéressante moi je voudrais juste
interrogé sur / en fait ce qui a été
offert dans la discussion entre cette
coopération
nantes rennes brest angers saint nazaire
on parle des métropoles mais en réalité
une grande innovation était quand même
la création ces pôles métropolitains qui
sont des sectes des syndicats mixtes
ouverts ou concernés et qui sont des
lieux de coopération où les frontières
sont des frontières de projet à la
demande et non des frontières au sens
des compétences et des collectivités
telles qu'on entend dans notre
organisation en france administratives
et moi je voulais vous interroger sur ce
rôle finalement des des pôles
métropolitains dans dans l'ex dans
l'ouest de la normandie réseau des
villes moyennes autour de la ville
centre qui est qui et quand et qui
couvrent à 1,3 million de personnes il
ya une quarantaine de villes moyennes
avec caen qui coopèrent et qui travaille
sur tous les sujets et je voulais vous
interroger sur sur l'importance
finalement de ces pôles métropolitains
qui certes n'ont pas forcément de
compétences qui peuvent en acquérir mais
en tout cas qu'ils permettent de traiter
de tous les sujets y compris seul mais
du bioart exemple l alimentation dans
les cantines et qui pourraient d2 de
contractualisation très extrêmement
souple et qui pourrait coller avec cette
notion de différenciation territoriales
telles qu'elles pourraient être portées
dans la loi cadre des et est ce que
finalement métropole ou pas est-ce que
c'est pas m le pôle métropolitain qui
est la solution la plus adaptée pour
donner la souplesse idéal
merci beaucoup sonia cl
oui merci beaucoup madame la présidente
et merci beaucoup de vos interventions
madame la présidente charge johanna je
suis très sensible à cette idée
d'abord à votre vision très nuancée
objective et des métropoles que je
partage et à cette idée qu'on est dans
une troisième étape qui je trouve repose
effectivement sur trois piliers une
gouvernance beaucoup plus intégratrice
des petites communes c'est passe par les
conseils des mères mais il ya bien
d'autres formes de gouvernance qui
peuvent justement permettre à ce que des
communes et des maires de petites
communes
auparavant ne se sentait pas appartenir
à la métropole et aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'elle a qui sont la gouvernance
est un levier extrêmement important pour
cette vision intégratrice en tout cas de
de l'espace métropolitain
la deuxième chose c'est la dimension
démocratique on a beaucoup parlé culture
je crois beaucoup à la valeur symbolique
de la culture dans le sentiment
d'appartenance mais ça passe aussi par
la question démocratique et là il ya des
formes aussi de consultation
d'organisation qu'il faut absolument
accélérer dans certaines métropoles au
regard de leur diversité moi je suis
tout à fait vraiment alors là d'accord
avec vous sur l'a10 fille de la
diversité des métropoles et parfois les
quelques difficultés que rencontrent
certaines parce qu'elles sont dans des
territoires différents
et enfin troisième pilier vous l'avez
évoqué c'est la question de la
coopération avec ce qu'on appelle
l'hinterland où les collectivités
contrat de réciprocité on a beaucoup
parlé de la région j'aimerais aussi
parlé du département parce que quand on
une métropole à ce qui est pour le cas
pour la métropole rennaise comprend plus
de la moitié des habitants du
département
il ya un vrai sujet dans leurs relations
de coopération entre départements voire
même au delà de ça dans les compétences
qui s'exerce entre la métropole et un
département délégation de compétence
on peut imaginer beaucoup de choses et
je trouve que là il y aurait aussi
matière à approfondir ses relations pour
que la question et je termine là bien
sûr des politiques publiques et
l'efficacité de l'action publique envers
les habitants soient mieux perçue parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un peu compliqué
est en tout cas plus efficace en tout
cas merci beaucoup de vos propos si
beaucoup s'ils
ils apprennent à notre collègue didier
rambaud
merci madame sera rapide parce que
c'était à peu près dans le même esprit
que que civile robert effectivement dans
mon département d'isère je m'intéresse
beaucoup à la relation métropole
territoires périphériques
c'est clair que lorsque ces métropoles
ont été créés on a senti des dynamiques
nouvelles
est-ce que les territoires pour
périphériques en profiter de cette
dynamique ou au contraire ce que les
fractures se sont accentuées
j'ai l'impression en lisant une ya
quelques temps une étude france
stratégie qui avait autant de situations
différentes qu'il existait de deux
métropoles donc ça m'intéresse d'avoir
votre retour à sujet est aussi de savoir
partir de là est ce que vos collègues
sur la question du 10 des périmètres
actuels des métropoles ont un regard
souhaite que ces périmètres et voulu ou
pas deuxième question la relation
département métropole là aussi quand les
métropoles ont été créés on avait bien
compris à l'époque c'était aussi pour
absorber les compétences du département
j'ai l'impression depuis deux ans nous
trois ans que ce sujet est mort qu'on en
entend plus parler
mais savoir un petit peu aussi votre
votre regard à ce sujet j'aurai une
troisième question mais j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que mon collègue
philippe dallier byron dessus c'est sur
la métropole du grand paris aussi
d'avoir voilà kaka qui n'a pas les des
compétences aussi complète est aussi
clair que les autres métropoles
françaises
merci merci didier donc sur la
suggestion de notre collègue charles
guené on propose de rassembler de toute
pression parce qu'elle est s'articule si
je puis dire les jeunes
donc charles c'est à toi ensuite
philippe dallier notre collègue guy
benarroch donc si on peut effectivement
garder la concision pour que nos
collègues qui doivent partir puissent
entendre les réponses merci beaucoup et
longer j'ai oublié laurent pardon merci
la présidente effectivement nos
questions et nos préoccupations se
recoupent et tout d'abord pour pour ceux
d'entre nous qui ont consisté au texte
sur les métropoles je crois que on a eu
le de vos sens direct façon on sait le
jeu consistait à savoir à reconnaître la
ville dans l'amendement qui était
proposée par par le collègue et c est
effectivement et ben on voit très bien
que la différenciation est déjà là à
titre personnel j'ai déjà fait un
rapport sur la métropole de lyon quai
qui était déjà dans la différenciation
au point de reconnaître et moi j'étais
particulièrement intéressé parce qu'on
les pôles métropolitains ou
la troisième génération des des
métropoles
parce qu'on voit bien que vouloir faire
des métropoles par tout ça n'est pas
concevable et que c'est plutôt les des
pôles métropolitains qui sont et là on
est plutôt dans le conventionnement
stratégique et je veux dire c'est cet
autre chose que l'intégration totale qui
à mon avis n'est pas de mise pour
certains territoires parce que je sais
que c'est plus facile à gérer
fiscalement mais enfin je partage avec
vous simplement sur la gouvernance
on va dire que et d'ailleurs c'est comme
pour les pôles métropolitains je crois
qu'on peut regarder sur la ruralité
parce que nous on a les ptr dans la
réalité on voit très bien que c'est une
articulation de conventionnement
stratégique est parfaite et les conseils
de développement nous sont effectivement
très utile je mettrai simplement un
bémol il faut arriver à les placer alors
juge les mettre à leur juste place
s'ils ne sont pas complètement dans le
gouvernant s'ils sont à côté sont là
pour suggérer sont là pour faire des
missions et à partir du moment où on a
mis ça en place
ça marche bien dernier point haut niveau
là fiscale enfin bon je veux pas rentrer
dans la fiscalité de même mais
simplement rester sur la crise kovy de
vous avez probablement les chiffres
comme nous lorsque le gouvernement nous
dit plus 3
recettes et je veux dire - et plus 0,4
de dépenses réelles
on sait globalement sur le pays a
normalement on arrive à 8,3 de dépenses
brutes
certes l'investissement a chuté de 3,4
on allait on a des chiffres alors le
ministre dise est hétérogène mais
simplement lorsque vous totalisé 22
millions c'est quand même le tiers de la
population de l'hexagone et au niveau de
la richesse c'est encore beaucoup plus
je marque je je pense que même si une
hétérogénéité vous globalement les
métropoles ne peuvent difficilement
avoir perdu et je pense qu'un problème
d'intégration plus tôt l'intégration
fiscale sur des territoires données
voilà ce que je voudrais ajouter
merci mercredi lente et coup d'essai la
matinée métropole puisque après vous
avoir entendu nous parlerons de la
métropole du grand paris en essayant de
voir quel pourrait être son avenir alors
un didier rambaud
nous travaillons ensemble sur le sujet
et ce qui nous intéresse effectivement
de tirer les leçons de ce qui se passe
dans les 19 autres métropoles jeu mais
paris lyon et marseille de côté parce
que même si effectivement pour une
question d'échelle
les situations ne sont pas tout à fait
comparable en tous les cas il ya
certainement des enseignements en tirer
et et je note d'ailleurs et je vais pas
dire que je m'en réjouis mais que les
critiques portées à l'encontre de
l'emitt des métropoles sont les mêmes
partout quelle que soit la taille de ces
métropole c'est la métropole château
fort utilisé l'expression de chailly
mais c'est aussi la métropole
coffre-fort
c'est à dire qu'on critique ces
métropoles en disant qu'elle ne se
préoccupe pas des territoires acquis
qu'à proximité
et puis on les accuse
concentrer la richesse fiscale en
oubliant effectivement de dire que ce
sont dans ces métropoles que l'on trouve
effectivement les zones les plus en
difficultés et la métropole du grand
paris qui est la plus riche de france la
plus riche d'europe est aussi celle où
la ségrégation territoriale est la plus
forte
et pire que cela elle s'est aggravée
dans les dernières années au lieu
effectivement de se réduire depuis la
mise en place de la métropole du grand
paris alors ceci étant dit mme agent
tire au moins une conclusion il ne peut
pas y avoir de métropole et je le dis en
regardant la métropole du grand paris
s'il n'y a pas de multi libre de
mutualisation je n'ai pas encore de
partage de mutualisation de la richesse
fiscale et il ne peut pas je le rajoute
y avoir de métropole s'il n'y a pas de
mécanisme de solidarité financière entre
la métropole et les communes qui la
composent
sinon enfin on peut toujours utiliser le
terme de métropole mais ça n'en est pas
une à mon sens si effectivement nous
n'avons pas au moins cela après se pose
la question effectivement du rapport de
cette métropole aux communes de du
rapport de la métropole au département
est chez nous c'est très compliqué
puisque les départements sont un tram et
38 mais ça pose aussi la question du
rapport de la métropole à la région
voilà j'ai j'ai pas de questions
particulières nous poser mais vous avez
dit parfaitement pointé les difficultés
alors je ne sais pas dans les 19 autres
métropoles quelle évolution
effectivement pourrait permettre
d'améliorer les choses
et d'ailleurs je pense que
conserver un modèle unique pour des
situations qui sont quand même très
différente impose aussi une difficulté
et pour conclure là dessus
malheureusement deux textes 4d il n'y
aura pas dans l'agenda parlementaire ce
qui nous renvoie à 2023 j'allais dire au
mieux 2022 effectivement je doute que la
première priorité d'un gouvernement
doublement installé soin de traiter ce
problème
40 le cde calendes grecques
notre collectif et blanche
merci donc je vais essayer d'être bref
puisque beaucoup de choses ont été dites
je rajouterais deux petits éléments de
questionnements le premier ont très
clairement aujourd'hui quand on étudie
les flux migratoires des métropoles on
s'aperçoit que la plupart des métropoles
sont quand même en flux migratoires
négatifs c'est-à-dire au perdu en fait
une partie de la population soit pour la
périphérie proche on va lire soit dans
des flux nationaux auxerre 10 à 10 il
faut étudier plus en détails en fonction
des métropoles c'est différent mais
néanmoins six mois s'accompagne aussi
d'un certain mouvement néo cons qu'on a
vu que certains
urbanisme sur l'orgue et ses 12 ans
décrit ces derniers temps qui a
processus de dé métropolisation
donc en fait on a un peu cette évolution
qui semble être celle qui est liée aussi
d'ailleurs au changement climatique en
fait aussi un impact environnementaux on
a ce phénomène en fait qui va peu à
l'encontre de la métropolisation
outrance qui était celle qui était faite
avec toutes les diversités dont on a
parlé dans la conception de métropole
voir dans l'appellation de métropole
voir dans l'appellation de pôles
métropolitains
donc ça c'était ma première éléments sur
lesquels j'aimerais avoir votre avis la
deuxième chose je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec les piliers dont on a
parlé tout ça repose aussi en dehors de
la gouvernance et de démocratie
citoyenne on va dire et de la
coopération interne tout ça repose aussi
sur le fait que dans certains nombre de
cas les métropoles sont non seulement
les coffres-forts mais sur l'édition
unique de distribution c'est à dire
qu'en fait nous n'avons plus affaire à
des métropoles de projets qui mettent en
place des projets par exemple sur les
mobilités lorsqu'elle perd des habitants
sur les périphériques elle développe des
transports en commun à l'intérieur des
métropoles mais qui serait capable de
diriger à l'extérieur mais nous avons
affaire à des métropoles qui distribue
des subsides et qui sont vécus comme ça
par les personnes parler parler parler
mer en fait je fais partie qui sont
inclus dans ces métropoles
donc ça c'est encore une deuxième
question est aménagé sur un troisième
élément des départements ça me paraît
essentiel moi je suis dans une métropole
où 90% du territoire et des habitats de
la métropole constitue le département
des bouches du rhône d'une manière
claire et donc dans lequel il était la
logique et la cohérence des projets
initiaux envisager la disparition la
fusion des deux voilà je suppose que je
suis pressé dans ce cas mais là on a un
réel problème
chers collègues donc je voulais
organiser
réponse qui veut démarrer madame la
présidente oui je veux bien
peut-être si j'essaie de reprendre des
questions dans l'ordre d'abord sur votre
question madame sur les pôles
métropolitains sujet que nous regardons
avec grande attention à un france
urbaine parce que france urbaine abrite
aujourd'hui 29 pôle métropolitain dans
ces échanges extrêmement nourrissons et
je partage totalement l'analyse qui est
la vôtre sur la question du périmètre de
projets je pense que c'est absolument
essentiel de se dire à chaque projet
quel est le bon périmètre pour ne pas
être dans une logique qui serait une
logique mathématique ou une logique
strictement institutionnels je partage
avec vous de fait une question qui peut
se poser dans nos pôles métropolitains
aujourd'hui si on veut continuer à
nourrir cette alliance des territoires
que j'appelle que j'appelle de mes voeux
c est ce que nos pôles métropolitains
ont vocation à continuer si je prends
l'exemple de l'ouest nantes rennes brest
angers est à cette échelle là où est-ce
qu'on doit réfléchir à intégrer des
villes moyennes
dans le pôle métropolitain ça fait
partie des sujets je crois qu'on
pourrait mettre à la réflexion
collective pour passer une étape
supplémentaire dans ces logiques de
coopération gagnant gagnant sur la
question culturelle nous l'avait évoqué
à l'échelle des métropoles
on peut aussi l'évoqué à l'échelle des
pôles métropolitains si on prend la
question nantes rennes par exemple que
ce soit dans la coopération de nos
opéras ou que ce soit sur le parcours
touristique pour reprendre ce sujet
nantes rennes mont saint michel saint
malo ça fait partie là aussi de la
réflexion de quel bon périmètre de
projets un mot sur la question région
développement économique métropole la
loi notre a acté le fait que le
développement économique était une
compétence partagée entre les métropoles
et les régions
et je crois que c'est impératif de
garder cette avancée législative de la
loi nôtre et je crois qui plus est que
le redécoupage des régions qui a amené
dans un certain nombre d'endroits des
grandes
région rend d'autant plus nécessaire de
maintenir ce leadership partagé si on
veut avoir à la fois des stratégies
qu'ils soient des stratégies offensives
sur le champ économique mais des
stratégies qui soit bien ancrée dans la
réalité économique de nos territoires et
ensuite le sujet c'est celui de la
capacité d'intelligence collective à
faire ensemble
je vais vous donner un exemple très
concret le président de la région des
pays de la loire s'appelait alors bruno
retailleau ce n'est un secret pour
personne que nos orientations politiques
sont loin d'être les mêmes
ça ne nous a pas empêchés de définir
ensemble les filières stratégiques les
filières d'excellence de développement
économique métropole région et je crois
que garder ce leadership partagé est
absolument essentiel si on veut garder
une forme d'agilité sinon on retrouvera
peu ou prou des logiques de
bureaucratisation qui ne viennent pas
servir l'efficacité du développement
économique dans la période quand on voit
à quel point le sujet de l'emploi qu'on
ne peut quand même pas traiter sans le
sujet du développement économique est
majeur c'est essentiel c'est la raison
pour laquelle je faisais une allusion
dans mon introduction au fait que même
l'état peut avoir tendance à oublier cet
élément je prends un exemple très
concret quand l'état a mis en place le
plan de relance pour le pays et que sur
le champ du développement économique il
met autour de la table dans un premier
temps uniquement les régions ils ne
respectent pas la loi notre nid dans
l'esprit ni à la lettre
il me semble que c'est qui plus est une
difficulté puisque deux fait les seules
collectivités qui sont sortis des
échéances électorales et donc qu'ils
sont dans les starting-blocks vous me
permettrez cette expression au moment où
on élabore nos programmes pluriannuels
et donc ils sont ré investir pour le
pays qui sont prêts à investir pour
contribuer à la relance de facto ce ne
sont pas les départements et pas les
régions qui sont en année d'échéance
électorale je rentre pas sur le débat
est ce qu elle d'avoir lu en juin ou pas
mais les métropoles dont moi j'insiste
le redécoupage en grande région valide
d'autant plus la question du leadership
partagé sur le champ du développement
économique sinon je pense que c'est la
bureaucratisation qui gagnera et pas
l'efficacité
de l'action un mot sur la question des
périmètres
est ce qu'il y à des volontés des
velléités d'agrandissement du périmètre
des métropoles actuelle c'est un débat
assez peu présent en réalité dans nos
échanges
aujourd'hui alors il peut y avoir des
diversités là aussi selon les
territoires
moi je crois que l'heure est plus aux
coopérations entre nos territoires tels
que c'est les évoqué tout à l'heure en
revanche je crois qu'il ne faudrait
quand même pas oublier la part
d'habitants qui sont aujourd'hui dans
nos villes et nos métropoles juste un
shift france urbaine
c'est au total quand on regarde
l'ensemble des collectivités locales
membres 37 millions de francs c'est donc
un moment donné il va bien falloir
parler aussi à tracer 37 millions de
français il me semble que de ce point de
vue les chiffres ne sont pas neutres
un mot sur la question métropole
département d'abord moi je crois
évidemment que la république est une et
indivisible et qu'on doit les uns et les
autres porter ça en revanche je crois
qu'il y à des situations différentes
entre les départements il ya des
métropoles et des départements il n'y a
pas de métropole
laval était de l'action publique ne
s'exerce pas de la même manière je crois
que c'est faire injure à personne y
compris de dire que d'un point de vue
démocratique le rôle d'un conseiller
départemental n'est pas le même n'a pas
la même visibilité quand il est dans 80%
des cas adjoint au maire et élus aussi
d'une métropole où quand c'est un
territoire où il n'y a pas cette double
dimension
je crois que ça reste un sujet à creuser
à titre personnel quand le gouvernement
avait proposé la fusion métropole
département pour les cinq plus grandes
métropoles en taille du pays je n'avais
pas retenu cette option
considérant que vieil adage qui dirait
plus vous avez de bataillon plus vous
avez de pouvoir ne s'appliquait pas
forcément aux enjeux contemporains
je crois que nos métropoles elles ont
besoin de garder de l'agilité je crois
que si on veut que les métropoles elle
puisse être comme vous le disiez ses
phares ces villes qui ne sont pas des
îles et qui travaille en résonance avec
les uns et les autres je ne suis pas sûr
que c'est l'absorption de tous
les professionnels par exemple de
l'action sociale du département qui
permet cela dans ma situation
territoriale nous avions déjà intégré
les compétences tourisme par exemple est
donc là aussi les réalités sont diverses
en revanche je pense qu'il peut avoir
ici ou là un certain nombre d'éléments
de clarification certain nombre de
présidents métropole témoigne du fait
que y compris quand ils veulent pousser
plus loin l'intégration avec les
communes les enjeux de pouvoir entre
métropole et départements s'oppose aux
logique d'intégration plus forte
métropole commune et et là un moment
donné il faudra bien assumer cette
réalité et regarder comment on peut la
dépasser deuxième piste de travail sur
le champ de l'action sociale j'y reviens
je crois qu'on aurait tout à gagner à se
dire dans le monde de demain on ne peut
plus avoir des grandes villes qui ont
des grands ccs et des départements qui
ont des grands centres cms à un moment
donné la question du guichet unique quel
que soit le pilotage d'ailleurs doit
pouvoir se poser si on regarde les
choses vues du point de vue de l'usager
un mot sur la solidarité financière que
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
peut-être partager le fait que là aussi
il ya des choix qui sont impossibles
j'évoquais la ds et danthez tout à
l'heure nous dans l'élaboration la
manière dont a conçu la dotation de
solidarité communautaire on donne dans
nos critères en quelque sorte une forme
de primes aux petites communes ont fait
le choix d'utiliser ce levier pour
renforcer la péréquation ça veut dire
que les instruments existent la manette
question et la manière dont on peut s'en
saisir aujourd'hui
enfin tu dois dire une chose sur des
métropolisation
et cette musique d'actualité qui nous
dit finalement les métropoles vont
perdre des habitants après la crise
sanitaire aspirations jardin maison
c'est d'abord je crois qu'il ya une
réalité sociale c'est pas chaque
français qui peut être dans ce type de
choses et deuxième chose c'est que pour
l'instant dans nos métropoles je ne dis
pas que ça va pas arriver mais je dis
que à date on ne le constate pas je le
lis dans la presse je le lis dans les
articles chez moi je continue à devoir
ouvrir nombre de classes chaque année
parce que la ville de nantes gagne 4000
habitants par an ça ne veut pas dire que
ce phénomène ne va pas arriver mais je
me méfie un peu kg cette prudence sur
ses effets qui nous sont annoncés et que
à ce stade on ne perçoit pas totalement
j'ajouterai et je dirai un mot pour
finir là-dessus donc nos métropoles
elles sont sur deux pour cent du
territoire français je crois que c'est
une chance pour la transition écologique
dans notre pays parce que quand on a dit
des métropoles dans les mots dont les
accable sont les responsables de la
densification
moi je sais pas comment on est pour la
transition écologique et pour
l'étalement urbain
intellectuellement ça ne marche pas ça
ne veut pas dire que la densification
pose pas de questions ça veut pas dire
qu'on doit pas construire autrement ça
doit pas dire qu'on peut pas se poser
les questions de respiration mais en
tout cas on a là des choses à regarder
et je terminerai par un questionnement
que je soumets bien volonté à la
sagacité et la capacité d'invention du
législateur je crois sur ces sujets de
transition écologique qu'on a à
réfléchir à la manière dont sont
évidemment tomber dans une logique de
décroissance
on pourrait imaginer que demain les
seuls où les principales ressources
fiscales des villes ne soient pas
uniquement les zones d'activités
économiques
parce que si on veut donner de la valeur
aux enjeux de transition écologique
il faudra bien à un moment se demander
comment les terres qu'on réserve à la
dimension naturelle pour le dire de
manière rapide
pourrait avoir une valeur économique
fiscal je ne sais pas il ya là des
mécanismes à inventer sans que ça
pénalise des communes qui du coup se
retrouverait en difficulté en tout cas
je crois qu'il ya là une forme de
changement de paradigme sur lequel se
serait tout à fait intéressant de
pouvoir travailler ensemble et je
terminerai par dire que pour moi
l'argument qui plaide le plus pour cette
alliance des territoires ce sont les
enjeux de transition écologique
70% des habitants habitent dans les
villes aujourd'hui pas en france mais à
l'échelle de l'europe à l'échelle du
monde
ce phénomène macro il va se poursuivre
en réalité en tout cas c'est une de mes
convictions et donc si les métropoles ne
s'occupe que de leur internat lité
écologique et ne se pose pas la question
des externalités se pose pas la question
de dire que à un moment on est
responsable pas simplement de nos
propres émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais de ce qui se passe dans
l'hinterland même si je vous avoue que
je suis pas tout à fait à l'aise avec ce
mot hinterland parce que quand on dit
interne en france les territoires
périurbains et ruraux à partir du point
de vue de la métropole et est donc là
aussi je crois que dans le vocabulaire
on pourrait essayer d'inventer des
nouvelles choses je crois donc que la
transition écologique elle nous impose
en réalité de passer à une alliance des
territoires la plus effective possible
merci de votre réponse très complète
madame monsieur vous regarde
oui prêt à terme non madame la
présidente je regardais quelques
couvertures en recrutant madame roland
sur voyez c'est très récent le
classement des villes qui ne veulent
plus où loeb ce au moins de novembre
quitter les métropoles c'est très
intéressant dans ses articles c'est
qu'on ne fait que des portraits de
familles qui quittent une métropole pour
une autre métropole et mais en pensant
que quitter paris c'est quitter les
métropoles ça me fait un peu ça me fait
un peu rigoler mais je je je vous dis ça
parce que je pense qu'il est important
aussi peut-être que change on change de
lunettes sur sur les villes en dessous
les métropoles
quand vous regardez aujourd'hui la
définition d'une ville moyenne ces vingt
à cent mille habitants
alors entre une ville de 20 mille et une
ville cinq fois plus importante je pense
pas qu'on a la même réalité comme
citoyen et on n'a certainement pas la
même réalité comme élu local
surtout si on situe dans un bassin à
plus ou moins 100 km d'une grande
métropole
et ça ce set cette petite dentelle a
fait rentrer
la question des petites villes et des
villes moyennes des grandes villes et
des métropoles à mon avis elle et elle
est à préciser dans les auditions que
nous avions fait et je ne trouvais pas
vraiment passionnante je vous le
conseille vraiment pierre weiss qui a
été un directeur polytechnique alors
c'est un livre est extrêmement simple a
écrit une france des territoires défis
et promesses et pierre weiss et on est
avant la crise sanitaire avait une
véritable action une c'est un travail de
comparaison notamment avec nos voisins
allemands sur la question de des petites
industries
ça rejoint un petit peu ce que le
gouvernement a prôné avec les 150 143 ch
c'est plus territoire d'industrie j'ai
pu le chiffre en tête est exactement
mais je crois qu'il ya vraiment eu un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui sur le maillage
territorial du fait notamment de cette
crise sanitaire qui va alors moi j'en ai
la conviction durablement changer les
choses
sur la question du télétravail même si
les chiffres que nous avons aujourd'hui
montre que les entreprises françaises
sont pas encore très allantes sur cette
question là mais il ya un
ya un engouement citoyen qui va être
très très important et que le
retentissement notamment sur
l'organisation spatiale est sûre alors
cédé formidable opportunité je trouve en
termes de logement puisque la
transformation de milliers de mètres
carrés de bureaux en logements
potentiels même si c'est beaucoup plus
simple à dire qu'à faire dans la réalité
mais il ya un sujet là dessus tout comme
sur la modification des sur la
modification des pratiques commerciales
hélas les villes résilientes que vous
appelez de vos voeux me rolland je pense
peuvent trouver des vraies opportunités
alors à leurs portes aujourd'hui par de
la requalification
juste ce chiffre il est sorti ce
week-end une bride son embauche 4500
livreurs et ça pose aussi la question
quand on connaît c'est une étude qui a
fait le ceo s'il ya quelques années
quand on connaît le niveau de précarité
et le faible niveau de protection de ces
personnes
il est danger qu'ils prennent tous les
jours ça pose vraiment une question
aujourd'hui à la fois d'organisation de
la ville et de coexistence des
populations donc il ya plein de sujets
la tuque pas de nourriture
il ya beaucoup de choses qui auraient
été leach parce que vous avez
effectivement raison c'est par les
questions de changement climatique
on parle pas beaucoup on parle pas assez
des dérèglements climatiques et de tous
les adultes les suites soient les
périodes de canicule soit les gros
arrêts effectivement la ville elle doit
être
elle doit être résiliente et et je sais
que les métropoles travaille beaucoup
sur votre sur ces questions la question
de la densité de où s'arrête
l'urbanisation et la densité on l'a mis
dans notre rapport elle doit être
raisonnée adapté parce que ça fait 20
ans je suis architecte urbaniste a donc
des questions aux poussins densifier
mais il ya aussi des limites à cette
densification et elle se fait aussi sous
certaines conditions
il faut que la nature le l'être humain
il a besoin de sentir la nef d eux
oui oui c'est ce qu'on a écrit c'est ce
que nous avons
et est en fait oui on a besoin d'être en
contact avec la nature avec la
biodiversité et ça je pense que toutes
les métropoles en général on l'a noté
elles l'ont pris en compte mais par
contre que l'on voit aussi c'est que les
gens n'ont plus forcément les moyens
d'habiter dans la métropole centre et
ont donc on humanise à 10 15 km
ça coûte moins cher et dans sa coupe
moins cher ce mais ça coûte moins cher
sur le court terme mais mais pas sur le
long terme et il faut vraiment bon là je
pense que la loi climatique qui s'est
passé ou qui doit être en train de
passer
elle va stopper tout ce qui concerne les
zones
bonn les grandes zones d'activités en
périphérie et en particulier les grands
centres commerciaux
on pourra construire on est sur un avis
en ce moment à la section aménagement du
territoire haussier sur les sur les
commerces où on peut pas et on a tous
aussi et la crise le montre aussi de
rien enfin de requalifier nos centres
anciens de faire un état des lieux de ce
qui se passe où est-ce qu'on peut
réhabiliter mais il ya des quartiers
aussi qu'on peut qu'on pourra pas
réhabiliter qu'il faudra qu'il faudra
reconstruire mais ce genre de de travail
nécessite on en revient aux besoins de
concertation ça doit se faire sur le
temps long c'est pas sur le tanga mandat
qu'on peut réfléchir et en fait on a
quelque part besoin d'élus visionnaire
qui réfléchissent sur le long terme et
embarqués la population s'est pas
forcément évident il ya un vrai travail
de savoir comment on va chercher les
habitants pour travailler sur le sur le
long terme en fait il y allait
effectivement par par étapes
on va déjà pas mal merci merci beaucoup
madame merci madame la prison merci
monsieur j trouvé notre débat
extrêmement riche intéressant qui en
fait nous réconcilier avec une chose
sans doute c'est la conviction qu'il n'y
a pas une vérité qu'il y ait une
complexité des choses et que l'on
travaille tout sur cette notion de
durabilité et le développement durable
en choix définis bien ces trois
composantes qui nourrissent notre
réflexion qui sont notre objectif c'est
cette espèce sociétal avec la place de
l'homme et l'action l'homme au sein de
son environnement le volet
environnemental mais aussi le volet
économique et donc c'est un sujet très
complexe avec mais moi je suis heureuse
de vous entends le constat qu'en france
nous avançons beaucoup par excès et par
correction d'excès nous avons eu depuis
les années 70 dont beaucoup de
territoires de france une tendance est
une inspiration et une action qui a
consisté à faire d'une extension urbaine
c'est à dire un étalement urbain qui
correspondait à un mode de vie d'une
époque moi je porte aucun jugement de
valeur
et aujourd'hui on a un autre regard et
dit qu'il faut construire les choses
autrement vous revenir sur un mot qui
fait peur
la densification mais les villes du
moyen âge qui n'était pas invivable
étaient des villes assez dense n'est
construite avec un sentiment
d'acceptabilité
[Musique]